another day another embarrassment to the
United States around the world by Donald
Trump yesterday the United States became
the single solitary only country not to
sign on to the Paris climate agreement
and the backstory of this is that
shortly after becoming president of the
United States Donald Trump pulled the
United States out of the Paris climate
deal with several months ago this is an
agreement that is meant to fight
greenhouse gas emissions and try to
limit global warming to only two degrees
Celsius by 2050 and yesterday we learned
that Syria has signed on to the Paris
climate agreement which now leaves the
United States as the only country that
is not going to be signing on to the
Paris climate deal at first when Trump
pulled out Nicaragua and Syria were also
staying out of the deal so the United
States was won over the three countries
now the United States is the only
country Syria got in yesterday
Nicaragua initially did not want to be a
part of it but because they felt that
the deal didn't do enough to limit
emissions and pollution but eventually
they realized hey it's better than
nothing so we are going to sign onto it
how do you justify this right I mean is
this American exceptionalism of some
kind how do you see this as an American
and think it's good that the United
States is the one country that's not
going to be a part of this deal there's
two ways that I see to rationalize this
right one would be the u.s. is smarter
than every other country in other words
we've somehow figured out in the u.s. or
Trump is figured out which is almost
delusional to believe we've figured out
in the u.s. something that no other
country has figured out about why
signing on to this deal would be a bad
idea the other possibility is the u.s.
is so different from every other country
in the world that while it might be fine
for all those other countries to sign on
to the Paris climate deal it would not
be in the American best interests to
sign on to the Paris climate deal at
least explain the rationale because the
truth is that neither of those ideas are
actually true and I was kind of shocked
that Trump didn't have the respect and
decency to just sign on to it and then
ignore it kind of like he's doing with
Russian sanctions right it
wouldn't be a new thing for Trump to
publicly or on paper do what looks
better but then just not do it in the
end because the truth is that this is a
very general agreement to try to limit
global temperatures from increasing more
than two degrees above pre-industrial
levels which would require pretty
significant changes from every country
that is involved here and of course the
target date is 2050 right so Trump could
sign on to this he's not going to be
President for most of the time that you
would actually have to make the changes
to hit this target by 2050 the agreement
doesn't even tell each country how
they're supposed to do this but it says
hey each country can come up with their
own plan for how to do this so why isn't
Trump doing it well optics I think Trump
sees himself as the tough guy who's not
going to be bullied on this climate
Panzi nonsense by other european
socialists like a manual McCrone or
whoever right I mean crazy of course
he's not a socialist Trump does want to
roll back a bunch of Obama regulations
like for example the clean power plan
which would have reduced carbon
emissions by 2030 to 32% lower than in
2005 Trump wants more coal right he's
been very adamant about trying to
breathe life into an industry that is
naturally dying in the United States so
those are some of the reasons Trump is
opposed to this there is some good news
hidden in this or not really in it but
kind of around it which is that a bunch
of states and cities in the US have said
we're going to carry out our plans as if
the United States were in the Paris
climate agreement California is making
major strides in wind and solar and
geothermal Iowa is now getting 35% of
its energy from wind Washington State is
getting a majority of electricity from
hydroelectric and I know hydroelectric
is not renewable in a sense in the same
sense that wind and solar are renewable
but still hydroelectric electric is
better than coal for example and even
Texas is seeing more wind power
generation which they should right
this has these huge open plains where
there is significant potential for wind
power generation and of course Texas
seen as oil country in many ways but
even Texas is generating more and more
electricity more and more power from
wind which is great and at the at the
sort of company level sounds like
they're bowling upstairs today at the
company level we have many companies
going green because it's good for
business right it's more economically
viable to go green every single year and
not a big surprise but we also learned
yesterday this is so funny Trump is not
going to be invited to the climate
change summit being held in France later
this year and why would he be right what
would Trump's presence at a climate
change summit do the guy is a denier and
he heads the one country that is not
going to be part of the Paris climate
agreements what his presence would be a
distraction it would distract or hold
back productive discussions and that's
where this becomes the issue right
because even though trumpets think that
this is all gray the Europeans or
sissies who cares if Trump isn't invited
to play in their sandbox the reputation
of the United States around the world is
being destroyed because whatever the
Trump is say about screw them and
Trump's not going to be pushed around he
doesn't want to be there anyway we are
moving towards a world where when you
want to have a serious conversation
about important issues like for example
climate change or green energy you don't
even invite the President of the United
States and that is an embarrassment for
the United States period whether the
trumpets ever see it or acknowledge it
whether Donald Trump ever sees it or
acknowledges it the fact that the United
States and the President of the United
States
need not even be invited to the serious
big-boy table discussions about major
issues is a major change from when
President Obama was President of the
United States
what's next Liberia and Burma will adopt
the metric system and leave the US as
the one country using our system we are
the only country that has decided for a
combination of harebrained and fact-free
reasons to say we are not going to be
of the Paris climate agreement it is
pathetic it is embarrassing and it is
impacting the United States around the
world already discuss this with us on
our reddit discussion forum at david
pakman.com slash re d di t we'll take a
break and be joined by luke vargas from
seoul south korea who's been traveling
with the president well with he's been
following the president around well I
don't even want to say that that makes
it sound worse than it is he is part of
the media group that is with the
president in terms of the countries the
president is visiting anyway it's very
late in South Korea and Luke will join
us after the break
today's episode of the David Pakman show
is made possible in part by Warby Parker
eyeglasses Warby Parker recently did the
right thing and ditched advertising on
right-wing conspiracy website Breitbart
pulling their ads off and you can get
the free five-day home Tryon from Warby
Parker check out their glasses I use
them when I'm not wearing contact lenses
I started with the free at-home trial
they send you five pairs of glasses you
see which ones you like you send them
back and whichever one you pick they
will put your prescription into I like
this because I can actually show the
glasses to other people and not have to
just decide on the spot like in an
eyeglass store the eyeglass industry is
controlled by very few corporations that
keep the prices very very high even over
$300 for prescription glasses with Warby
Parker they start at just 95 bucks mine
costs that including lenses and for
every pair sold they give a pair to
someone in need so to try the five pairs
and support the David Pakman show go to
Warby Parker trial comm /t DPS